hi guys I'm Greg hi I'm a magnesite this
is ha I need a star from the tyro Magnus
channel i am from his channel Matt for
yo this guy did a video hey do we go
called how to react as a parody of like
how people do reaction videos all right
so funny right on that's so funny I
actually became friends with this guy
and the end i did a rap song on my
channel once co-writer right laughs
something i forgot to show me that i
know i don't think so but he actually
did the rat be for me oh really i didn't
he did like a follow-up verse on his own
channel and even disguised as a sick rap
ok the grey rapper I notice he's doing a
lot more rap videos now yeah and he's
got this like challenge thing going on
as channel I seen a couple of them where
it's like people submit wordwrap so what
rap along with really i guess i'm not
sure how different this one's going to
be but this video is called what rhymes
with Benedict Cumberbatch two minutes
and get this kind of wraps is this dude
right here on the right ok six [ __ ]
right he doesn't look like he'd be a
sick rapper you've done a nerdy he looks
a little nerdy well I'm into believe it
or not this guy has a tongue like you
wouldn't believe I'm sure you're gonna
want that I am right now I can't meet up
sorry I get all right on the family Jim
what is wrong with me cuzzo let's do it
who I am pretty chill sorry I'm
correcting you talk about Benedict
Cumberbatch so I had some guilt Heather
what's up with that he said whatever
will love your breasts but I think you
need to take your challenge
don't you match it sounds cumbersome but
second your cummerbund make it even
better than or did not just ugly tackles
and I just laid a general economy
everybody not kind of informal rash but
the liquor decide to that covers dragon
on the younger chap I'm not going to
come from a dump at that time Jackie the
head of that don't like that cabeto
benedict cumberbatch I've been addicted
to the class like a hobby dividing
breakfast at lunch Jack I wasn't excited
it wasn't bad to the hour later I was
sending it off the Hat for all my stuff
like every one of your hands ever come
to be but something you want to set that
up as well I'm a chicken my lusty crack
my back health exam for example and I
was like an exact what's our immigrant
when he wears a a check well he wasn't
collapse wasn't bad what do you sucker
is fun to laugh at it sound like when I
got the film is max on king with a
chicken four times as a lumberjack
always just we could entrust ourselves
with the bus I had to have a slumber way
you should get get another match well
you did to rub it the club in a bubble
back after that the aftermath yeah man I
thought what I want the man it's a
little of fumbling the belly can't
recover bad you got you come up in for
you coming up like a challenge you
thought what to stop me flattens after
the next cumberbatch egg now gonna do
cucumber patch haha so much Pikachu good
so much riding there that was really
awesome even with subtitles it's a
little hard to keep up with all that
going on in a lot there was a lot its
Anatomy its rhythm & wordplay is amazing
dude I can't believe you wrote that
that's pretty red I've seen longer wraps
from this guy like his flow is is just
incredible man he can he knows how to
slow it down I also to speed it up and
on the same beat absolutely and his
Reich his vocabulary he's got a wild
happy area by the nerdy thing works for
him it doesn't work with generate works
nerdy big word mind was going yeah yeah
Matt for you i won I'll oh no yeah you
should i do it yeah you let him use his
Cumberbatch why not batchi well yo
[ __ ] the bachelor homered well then
addicting you I will be been addicted to
his Cumberbatch when I was good at the
wrapping game again I don't even know
your I do you have your night nobody
cares this guy like does this a bit
serious hi I you could do stuff like
that you want to become like
professional you know is percussion like
every six months I get it sparked a lot
for a month where I like want to do it
is guys like a lifestyle built around
rapping yeah i mean if you can do it i
think it's even lco is he I think it's
effing it really is where you phone me
he's from okay it's got that Billy look
he looks like a recount it's always
going to Philadelphia so many pokemon
look at this we're like you mean right
now you got the most interesting
backdrop and I saw the link with linking
this guy could be the first like legit
nerdy round like a nerdy cute rapper guy
that is just awesome yeah so like when
you ladies I watching shirtless and just
subscribe to gym because there's no
reason not to I want to make sure I know
you do I love to sing for me nodding it
snapchat amia photo ruthless that nipple
action mmm I bet you've got a nice meat
but it got three nipples that is the
most men do mmm no it's really crazy I
don't know when you're talking about
nipple sometimes it hides is a mole it's
a look at this thing I promise me I know
it's that thing I don't think you most
men have third nipples look it up yeah
it's the thing i don't know somebody
actually was telling me about and then
showed me like live this model is
actually supposed to be a nipple but
it's turned into my don't know it just
it was we are maybe i was drunk
got a nibble on my penis show me doctor
said it was only this yeah but I'm like
no it won't go away i'm pretty sure it's
a nipple you got a nipple dick it's
right that it makes it harder potato
chips everywhere Greg caught me with
that were the honor what it shows no
shorten sad penis that are bad for you
guys guide to met for you and the real
reason the real reject that Anita star
check out her channel my channel you got
like funny [ __ ] on their books you got
funny we did it hey John and I need a
video on her channel oh my god no I can
watch I believe seven all right it
should still be all right why would it
not be it's all very upper if you are
under the age of 12 it is all the kind
of jokes suited for you kid absolutely
it is not adult material not so
appropriate moment you know I've had
some requests for you to do more
voiceovers so will you might have well I
do have a lovely voice you do you and
John both senator john too yeah
everything was out John ha I know you
think you cough is always got John yeah
not always about behind me a compliment
been looking guy Sean out of the car
good-looking guy that's all that's all
you are John you dunce a good-looking
boy do you think I'm good-looking axe
but yeah I think you and John are both
really good work like what sergeant
being I always really not be the best
situation these two gentlemen just like
just John and I are today we're gonna be
in time I would be willing for the
emotional connection and John for their
physical benefit yeah and I'm sorry
we're not in for everyone human being
this is where people think we're
let's suppose it oh we got so close oh
true the people we did behind my man is
he didn't yes me and her son was way
down my throat I some very lumps under
one with them I just go